oh you believe give
charity for the pleasure of
Allah the pleasure of
Allah oh you who believe read the
Quran every night of
Ramadan night of
Ramadan welcome oh
Ramadan
it is
Ramadan it is
[Music]
Ramadan dear brothers and sisters in
Islam and Humanity asalam
Al May the peace the mercy and the
blessings of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
be on all of
you welcome to the show Ramadan a date
with Dr Zakia I'm your host Yousef
Chambers and today we will be discussing
the topic common errors committed by
Muslims during the month of
Ramadan so without further Ado let's ask
the first question of Dr Zak Dr
Zakir what are the reasons behind
Muslims continually falling into these
same errors Ramadan after
Ramadan
alhamdulillah
[Music]
the main reason that Muslims keep on
committing the same errors in the month
of Ramadan regarding the rules and
regulations of fasting is lack of
knowledge of the dean of the religion of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and the major
reason for this lack of knowledge is
because most of the Muslims they do not
read the word of Allah subhana wa tala
they do not read the Quran with
understanding neither do they read the
Hadith the authentic sayings of the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
Sall Ali wasallam what we Muslim should
do is read the Quran with understanding
read the sayings of the prophet and the
S of the Prophet then inshallah at least
we will have the basic knowledge of our
Dean including the rules and regulations
of fasting and Allah subhana wa ta'ala
he always opens up his pathway he gives
guidance to the Muslims but there is a
criteria to whom does he guide Allah
says in the
Quran in anab chapter number 29 verse
number 69 that those who strive in the
way of Allah subhana ta'ala those who do
J Allah subhana wa ta'ala opens his
Pathways for them so the criteria for us
to get the guidance of Allah subhana wa
tala the criteria for us where Allah
subhana wa taala will open open up our
Pathways is to strive in his way to do
J and Allah says in the Quran in chapter
number
16 verse 43 as well as Surah Amya
chapter number 21 verse number 7 Allah
says which means if you do
not possess or if you
doubt then ask the person who possesses
the knowledge if if you doubt anything
ask the person who's
knowledgeable and alhamdulillah we have
in our
umah several Muslims who are scholars in
this de so it's our duty to ask these
Scholars these people who have the
knowledge of Islam regarding the rules
and regulations of our Dean as far
as fasting is concerned which is one of
the important pillars of Islam every
Muslim should know at least when is the
time for fasting what are the basic
rules and Regulation and today in this
age of Science and Technology it's very
easy to find it is only the negligence
of a Muslim that makes him unaware of
these things it's very easy today to
know when is the time for fasting when
does Fast begin when the time of when is
the time forar for breaking the fast
what are the things that break the fast
etc etc it is mainly due to the
negligence and ignorance of the Muslims
that we regularly keep on falling and
committing the same
mistakes furthermore what are the common
errors that are made by Muslims during
the holy month of
Ramadan the common errors committed by
the Muslims in the month of Ramadan can
be broadly classified into four
categories the first category is the
common errors committed by Muslims
regarding the obligatory rules and
regulations of fasting the second
category is the common errors committed
by Muslims which are contradictory to
the Sunnah of
fasting the third
category is the errors committed by
Muslims
mainly due to neglecting the obligatory
duties in Islam
and indulging in Acts which are
prohibited
and the fourth category is the other
common errors committed by Muslims in
the month of
Ramadan clearly Dr Zaki it's going to be
difficult for us to um discuss all of
the common errors made by Muslims during
the month of
Ramadan in this one interview but over
the next 32 days we will inshah try to
cover those issues but could you just um
state or list the most grievous mistakes
made by Muslims in the month of
Ramadan as far as the common errors that
fall in the first two categories
inshallah we'll be discussing in detail
in the next insh 30 days I will
inshallah speak about the common errors
committed in the third and fourth
category before we discuss categories
three and four can we at least list the
most common errors from sections 1 and
two the most Grievous amongst the errors
in the first category that is errors
committed regarding the obligatory rules
and regulations of fasting is the most
common is that Muslims many of times
they don't do the Nia for fasting
intention is very important without Nia
without intention the fasting is not
accepted so making intention is
obligatory and we'll be discussing this
inshallah in detail insh tomorrow the
second error is that many of times
Muslims even after the F aan has started
yet they continue eating and they think
that the end ofur time is only at the
end of the FJ aan in fact the moment the
fjer aan starts the moment the beginning
of dawn starts the S time ends so this
is error which normally nullifies or
invalidates the fast the third error in
the first category is that many people
they delay paying their
Z and many times they pay after
the Salah if we pay the Zak
after then it is like normal it it does
not come under the Zak so these three
are the most Grievous in the first
category the common errors committed in
the second category that is errors that
are contradicting the Sunnah of the
fasting is number
one many people they skip
the some people they have an early suur
that is they have theur one or two hours
before the fud time in factur is a
blessing every Muslim should have it and
the prophet said we should delay The Sur
as much as possible we should have it
till just before the F
time the third mistake committed by
Muslims in this category is that they
delay opening their fast they delay
thear and our Prophet malli wasallam
said that the people will be good as
long as they hasten in
breaking thear that means immediately
after Sunset they should break
thear the fourth common error in this
category is that many Muslims they read
unauthentic
Dua during
ifar the most authentic Dua as far Asar
is concerned
is inshallah which means
that my thirst is quenched the veins are
moistened and the a is
near inshallah God willing the reward is
near God willing and some people when
they read this Dua for breaking the fast
they say it before breaking the
fast before they put their date in the
mouth they say this and it's called
contrary to the meaning the meaning says
that my thirst has been
quenched my thirst has been quenched and
the veins have been moistened your
thirst cannot be quenched before
breaking the fast so normally it should
be said after you eat the k after you
have water and you're satisfied maybe
after some minutes after you break the
fast then you can read this
Dua inshah
which
means my thirst has been quenched the
wains have been
moistened the reward is near inshallah
God
willing the
sixth common error made by Muslims in
this category is that many Muslims they
eat excessively during ifar and many of
them even eat throughout the
night the seventh common error is that
many of them they are negligent as far
as is concerned
because is not a they think it is no
problem if a Muslim misses T though T is
not a it's a very important Sunnah and a
Muslim who misses T is missing a great
deal of
reward and many Muslims who perform Tavi
they read T very fast 10 mil hour they
try and finish it in a short time and
they defeat the purpose in fact you
should read with a moderate PA so that
people understand and they grasp the
message of Allah subhana wa tala the
ninth common error is that those who go
for in the mus many of them they
socialize during ITA as though it's a
time to meet people and friends which is
totally contrary to the
Sunnah the 10th common error is that
many of the Muslims think that the is on
the 27th night of
Ramadan and they only worship Allah
subhana tala on this night in fact our
beloved Prophet M wasallam
said search for the in the odd nights of
the last 10 days the last Ash the 10
days therefore Kad can fall either on
the 21st night or 23rd or 25th or 27th
or 29th so this is one of the common
errors made by Muslims the 11th common
error is that they spend their time
during Ramadan in unproductive work
rather than spending in zikar and
worshiping Allah subhana tala they
should spend the time rather for
offering besides the compulsory Salah
the the voluntary Salah the sunah Salah
the 12th error made by the Muslims is
that they should do Dua
the 13th is they should ask for
forgiveness this month of
forgiveness 14th is they should read the
Quran as much as
possible to get the blessings of Allah
subhana wa tala the 15th is that they
fast and they keep themselves hungry but
basically they're not mentally prepared
for that
fast and it is as though they're staying
hungry but the main purpose of fasting
to acquire tawa is not
obtained this was in brief regarding the
second category can you mention briefly
again categorize the uh common errors
made in the third
category the common errors committed by
Muslims in the third category that is
errors regarding negligence in
performing the far the obligate duties
in Islam is that
Muslims many of them they stay awake the
full
night they have a
early
and these
people they do not offer the F Salah
missing F Salah is a
sin many of them because they stay awake
the full night they sleep the full day
and they even miss the Z and the Salah
which is a grave sin they're trying to
acquire blessings and you are neglecting
the obligated duties which is totally
prohibited many of the
Muslims they do not give zakat those are
supposed to give zakat and zakat is one
of the pillars of Islam in which every
Muslim who has a saving of the nisab
level that is those who have a saving of
85 grams of gold they should give
2.5% of their savings every lunar year
in society it's called a zakat
and the fourth error in the third
category is that most of the Muslims
give zakat but they do not calculate the
zakat
properly as far as common errors
committed by Muslim month of Ramadan
that is indulging in prohibited acts the
most common is though these acts are
prohibited for a Muslim irrespective
whether it's a month of Ramadan or non-
Ramadan but specifically we should be
more careful we should be careful trying
to avoid these acts throughout a life
but in Ramadan we should be more careful
and the most common number one where
Muslims involve themselves is backbiting
and
slandering backbiting is a grave
sin and Allah says in the Quran in Surat
chap 49 verse number 12 that those who
backbite they are people who
eat the dead meat of their own
brother so backbiting and sanding is one
of the gravest sins the second common
error in this category
is Muslims many of them they use false
speech they tell lies during the month
of
Ramadan the third is they use abusive
language which is contrary to the spirit
of Islam and of Froman the fourth is
they use VGA
language and the fifth fifth is they
involve themselves in
gossiping the sixth
is some of them involve in false
action the seventh is many of the
Muslims to kill time they listen to
music and un Islamic
songs which is totally prohibited in
Islam the eighth common error is many of
the Muslims took time they watch un
Islamic television programs and un
Islamic
movies the ninth common error committed
by Muslim is that many of the Muslims
they read un Islamic magazines un
Islamic books and Islamic
pictures which all prohibited in Islam
the 10th common error done by Muslims in
this month is many of them they go to un
Islamic sites on the internet which is
again prohibited the 11th common error
is that
they spend
excessively and they commit
extravagance and the 12th is there is a
lot of wastage of food so this was in
brief
regarding the list of mistakes done by
Muslims commonly in the third category
that is indulging in Acts which are
prohibited and neglecting acts which are
far in
Islam so Dr zakya what are the other
common errors committed by Muslims
during the month of
Ramadan the other common errors ComEd by
Muslims in the month of Ramadan that is
the fourth category is number one is
that many of the Muslims they stay awake
the full night and then they sleep in
the day and they do the normal activity
at the night time and sleep in the
daytime they're converting day into
night and n today and the whole purpose
of fasting is
defeated the second error in this
category is that many of the Muslims
they remain lazy and they inactive
during the daytime which is contrary to
the spirit of fasting the third common
error is that many of the Muslims they
try and kill their time during the day
by
playing by amusement
by games which defeats the purpose
again the fourth common error is Muslims
they give lavish ifar parties and they
spend a lot of money many time to show
off the fifth common error many of the
Muslims they ask the wom folk in their
family to prepare a variety of dishes
forar and for thus making the wom in the
family spend the majority of the time in
the kitchen in fact the family should
spend most of the time in Remembering
Allah subhana wa tala and if the women
folk do more duas inshallah even the men
will benefit even their sin will be
forgiven
inshallah the sixth common error is that
many of the Muslims they
renovate the house and the shop in the
month of Ramadan spend more time in that
than remembering Allah subhana tala the
seventh common error is that many of the
Muslims they spend their nights instead
of remembering Allah subhana wa ta'ala
in activities which are unproductive for
example they spend their
time in excessive socializing after that
is the eight error ninth is many of the
Muslims they spend many nights and most
parts of their nights in
shopping the 10th common error is many
of the Muslims they spend most of the
time in the night in
eating the 11th is many of the Muslims
they spend their time in
robing and in loitering during the night
and the 12th commment error is the last
10 days of Ramadan are mainly the days
in which the Muslims should do more I
but most of the Muslims they spend time
in shopping in
celebrating and preparing themselves for
Eid and most of them spend time in
activities are unproductive rather than
spending their time in I these are some
of the other common errors which Muslims
commit and I hope inshallah that they
will abstain from these errors in future
insh so the next uh question is um are
there any common errors that you can
mention relationship to culture and
Country all the errors that I mentioned
earlier were General Muslims throughout
the world there are some errors which
are made mainly by people living in
certain country belong to certain
culture for example in the Indian
subcontinent that are people living in
India in Pakistan and Sri
Lanka during Ramadan many of the Muslims
in the night they play night
cricket and they spend most of the time
in night Cricket rather than doing I
Allah subhana wa Talala so this playing
night Cricket is more common in the
Indian
subcontinent now if you go to the Arab
countries especially the gulf countries
there many of the
offices many of the working places that
is in the market Etc they change their
timings they hardly work for a couple of
hours in the daytime and they open most
of the time during night so what happens
it encourages people to do shopping in
the night rather than of the day and
they get more
business and they're inviting people
rather in spending time in Remembering
Allah subhana wa ta'ala Muslims spend
their time in shopping and eating during
night time and furthermore those people
who are employed in the shops they
forced to come at night time because
it's the duty so these Muslims
preventing their
employees rather than remembering Allah
subhana wa tala the involv themselves in
business and spending most of their time
in activities which are not according to
the Sunnah Dr Zak are there to your mind
any important sunnas of the Prophet
Muhammad sallahu alaihi wasallam that
people avoid because they feel it will
nullify their fast yes there are a few
sunnas of the Prophet which many Muslims
avoid thinking it will break their fast
or it is Mak and the most important
Sunnah of the Prophet which people avoid
doing Ramadan is using theak using the
tooth stick many Muslims feel that if
they use this it is Mak the main reason
is there's aith of wasallam a Hadi which
is mentioned in s bukari volume number
three book of fasting Hadith number 1900
and four where the Beloved Prophet
mallalli wasallam said I swear by Allah
in whose hand is the soul of Muhammad
peace be upon him that the breath of the
person who
fasts is more sweeter to Allah than the
scent of musk now based on this Hadith
many Muslims think that if they use the
the breath the bad breath or the foul
breath of the person who fast will not
be there and it will not please Allah
that's the reason they avoid using sah
now these people they fail to realize
that when we use the stick Sak it does
not remove the
breath the foul breath or the breath
which people normally don't like of the
person who fast the Sak mainly brushes
the gums it cleans the teeth it helps in
keeping the teeth healthy but in no way
does it reduce the breath especially of
the person who fast and furthermore
there's a sun of the Prophet where
prophet wasallam he said
it's mentioned s bukari volume number
two Hadith number
887 aboved Prophet M wasallam said
that if it wouldn't have been too hard
for my um I would have made it
compulsory for them to use the Sak the
tooth stick before every prayer or to
use the toot stick while doing woo like
how wo is a requirement before Salah the
prophet if it wouldn't have been too
difficult for for the um you would have
made it compulsory to use the T stick
and here he did not mention any
exceptions other would have said I have
made it compos for my um except during
fasting this important Sunnah surely if
this would have been Mak while fasting
would have nullified the fast surely he
would have mentioned it so this Prov
that this is important Sunnah which
Muslims should continue doing even
during the month of Ramadan even while
fasting it will not nullify the fast
it's not Mak in fact it is must it's
encouraged and the other important
Sunnah which people neglect or avoid
mainly fearing that it will spoil their
fast or nullify their fast is putting
water in the nostrils sniffing the water
normally especially during woodoo so
many of the Muslims even when they do
woodoo they just get the water close to
the nose and touch the tip of the nose
to the water that's it they don't put
the water into the nostrils and they
clean their nose they don't sniff it
which is a requirement for Wu thinking
that if they sniff it may break the fast
water entering through the nose into
your throat will nullify the fast but
the chances are very negligible what our
beloved Prophet mallam said it's
mentioned a of Abu da volume number two
Hadith number 2360 our beloved Prophet
said that when you do woodoo sniff the
water excessively except in fasting so
normally when we do woodoo we sniff the
water excessively except in fasting
because in fasting if we sniff
excessively there are chances though
very negligible for it to enter the
throat and nullifying your fast but
normally when we put water in the
nostrils there are no Chan of it going
to the throat so only care that we have
to take while fasting is don't sniff
excessively but we have to put the water
in the nostrils and clean the nostrils
which is important Sunnah which many of
the Muslims neglect and they avoided
especially during Wu and here since the
prophet clearly mentioned except
fasting during the he said I would have
made it compulsory had it not been
difficult for my um there because he
doesn't say fasting it means that s can
be used while fasting and sniffing
should not be done excessively but
normally water should be put in the
nostrils while doing woodu so these two
important sunnas which people out of
ignorance they avoid during fasting
Dr Zakia next question is a very common
question and it's one that I'd like to
know the answer to as well it's um if
all the devils are chained during the
month of Ramadan how come people
continue to commit
sins and I do agree with you this is a
common question and I remember several
years back when I was in school and when
I heard this Hadith that the devils are
chin in the month of Ramadan immediately
the question that came to my mind and
the question that comes to many Muslims
mind and many non-muslims is that if the
devils are chained then how do people
how do human beings yet commit
sins this question is based on the Hadi
of mam which I mentioned earlier a had
of
Ahmed volume number two page number 230
Hadith number
7,148 which is also
repeated
in chapter number five Hadith number
21106 where the Beloved Prophet
said that o people the Blessed month of
Ramadan is
approaching and Allah has ordained for
you that you fast in this
month
and the Gates of Heaven will be open in
this month and the Gates of Hell will be
closed and Devils will be
chained in this month is a
night which is better than a thousand
months and a person who's deprived of
the blessing in this month is truly a
deprived person now when we give this
Hadith it clearly mentions that in this
month of Ramadan the Devils will be
Chained and a logical question if devils
are chained then how do human beings yet
commit
sins to make the people understand we
have to realize that when the devils are
chained it does not mean that the devils
are slain they have been killed they yet
present but they chained they're not
killed the power is yet there but it is
diminished for a better understanding I
like to give you an
example that when there is a lion or a
tiger who is free there are high chances
that he may kill you your life is in
danger but the moment that tiger or that
lion is Chained you are
safe you are safe as long as you
maintain a safe
distance after the Tiger has been
chained if you come too close to him
there are chances yet you can be killed
so as long as you maintain the distance
from the tiger who is Chained you are
safe similarly in the month of Ramadan
if you maintain a safe distance from the
Satan you'll be saved and if you read
the Quran Allah says in Surah Bak
chapter 2 verse number 168 be careful of
the toan of the footsteps of the devil
for he is to you an a enemy many places
Allah subhana tala says in the Quran
that be careful of the footsteps of the
devil Allah doesn't say that be careful
of the devil because a normal Muslim an
average Muslim who has average Iman when
he sees the devil in front of him he
will be careful for
example suppose there's a young girl who
comes to an average Muslim a young boy
who has average Iman if a young girl
comes and tells him that let's spend the
night together that Muslim will say
spending the night together with a girl
is Haram it is z he will immediately
object but that same girl if that girl
phones that young boy and speaks to him
on the phone the boy will say speaking
to a girl on the phone there's no
problem so he speaks to the girl for a
few times on the phone for a few minutes
later on the girl says let's go and have
some snacks in McDonald's on Ki Fried
Chicken having snacks for a few minutes
for half an hour with a girl in
McDonald's no problem so he goes and has
snacks with a girl and McDonald's later
on the girl says why not have dinner in
a restaurant having dinner with a girl
in restaurant for a couple of f no
problem then the girl says why not spend
the night together and then the boy says
spending the night together with a girl
no problem so this
is footsteps of the devil this is not
mentioned in the Quran this is just my
own example so what Allah warns us is
that be careful of
the the footsteps of the devil devil if
the Devil comes directly in front of an
average Muslim who has IM he will
abstain he will run away from it but
thean are the things which are
dangerous so what we have to realize
when the devil is
Chained his footsteps are
restricted so many of the sins are
prevented but if we go close to him then
the chances that we'll be overtaken by
the devil and commit a sin
are very high so what we have to be
careful that in Ramadan if we keep the
distance then the chance of committing
sin is less but if we go close to the
Satan even though he's chained like how
a tiger can walk even after he's chained
same the devil so this is my
understanding when the Beloved Prophet
said the devils are chain the devil
canot move but less distance so if we
keep the distance we'll be safe the
second reason that I feel is that in the
month of Ramadan
though the devils are chained we fail to
realize that the balance 11 months they
are free and the impact that the devil
has on the human beings for these 11
months it leaves those impact that
impression in the month of Ramadan to
give a better understanding I always
give the
example that there are drug pedlers
which try and get customers the
youngsters from the college from the
universities so what they do initially
they give the drug free and they entice
the youngsters for having drugs later on
after some time they charge a nominal
amount for that drug later on they
charge an exorbitant amount but by the
time the youngster is already hooked on
to the
drug so even if the drug dealer is not
there they will try and find where the
drug dealer is they will go out of the
way to find him and get the
drug and many of them even if the drug
pedler the drug dealer is imprisoned by
the law they will go out of the way to
find someone else they may go in a
chemist shop and buy mandri whatever it
is they are so much hooked on to it so
these people who have become
addicts to drugs or rather say addicted
to the Satan even though the Satan is
imprisoned the effect is yet there so in
this way we understand as a drug dealer
as a drug pedler even after he goes the
drug addict gets accustomed to that drug
so we human beings we accustomed to the
sin and even though the Satan is
imprisoned we keep on committing these
mistakes but mainly those people who
have become addicts fall in this
category so those who do major sin fall
in this category but the normal Muslims
the average Muslims who haven't become
addicted it's easy for them to stay away
from
sin and the third reason that I give
is that though there are some Scholars
who say that in this month of Ramadan
the strong Devils the Mars they
imprisoned the smaller ones are free so
they keep on committing mistakes but ACC
my
understanding the third reason
is
that though the devils are chained by
Allah subhana wa taala they can yet
whisper and one of the ways the Devils
try and get the human beings close to
them is by
whispering and Allah says in the Quran
in Sur Nas chapter number
114 verse number 1
to6 they whisper in the hearts of the
human beings and they withdraw amongst
them the Jin and Men it's talking about
the Satanist talking about the Devils
who whisper into the hearts of the human
being and the withdraw and among these
devils are the Jin and the human beings
so maybe Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
imprisoned the Devils who are the Gin
but the human beings V are yet free so
one category of devils that the Gins
have been imprisoned but the Satan are
even amongst the men that's what Allah
says
who are yet free and yet we have to be
careful of The Whisper Of The Devil the
Wasa this wasasa mainly is thing that
attracts toward the sin the sin they had
committed but the chances are less and
furthermore it's clearly mentioned the
full Hadi that Allah has ordained for
you in this month of Ramadan that you
should
fast only if you fast according to me
will the Devils be imprison that's
talking about the Devils that are going
to attract you so Allah says if you fast
Allah has ordained for you fasting and
the Devils will be put in Chains so the
Devils that after you if you fast surely
they'll be restricted the criteria for
us to be away from the Devil is to fast
if you fast with the proper
Nia seeking the of Allah subhana wa tala
surely the devil will not be able to
entice you and the best logical way to
prove this is if we check the crime
rate
of the Muslim countries during Ramadan
it goes down but if you check the crime
rate of the non-muslim countries in
Ramadan it is the same the reason is
that because they are not fasting the
non-muslims this devil yet has an effect
on
them because the Muslims are fast
if not all properly at least majority or
at least quite a large number so because
of that the crime rate in the Muslim
country in the month of Ramadan is low
as compared to the other months but the
crime rate in the non-muslim country is
approximately the same indicating
otherwise even the non-muslims they will
not commit any sins the criteria is that
you have to fast properly for the sake
of Allah subhana wa tala well the last
question today regarding
Prophet Muhammad Salli wasallam
statement which you mentioned in your
last answer regarding the fact the uh
the gates of paradise are open and the
gates of hell are closed does this mean
that we will be going to Paradise if we
die in this blessed month this again is
the same question of the same Hadith
same Hadith which occurred earlier of
musnad Ahmed Vol number two page number
230 Hadith number 7148 and it also
appears in sunai chapter number 5 Hadith
number 21106 again the same Hadith the
prophet said he told the people that the
Blessed month of Ramadan is approaching
and Allah has Ed for you that you fast
in this
month and in this month the Gates of
Heaven will be open and the Gates of
Hell will be closed and the Devils will
be chained in this month is the night
ofad which is more blessed than a
thousand
months and a person who's deprived of
the pleasures of the blessings in this
month is truly a deprived person here
again this is a common question that if
the Gates of Heaven are open and the
gates of hell are closed then anyone who
dies but natur will go to Jenna because
the Gates of Hell closed and jna open
does it mean that even if a non-muslim
dies in this month even he'll have to go
to Jenna the reply to this question is
when Allah says that in this month of
Ramadan the Gates of Heaven are open it
means the Gates of Heaven are inviting
you to enter
jenah that means that even if you do a
small deed Allah subhah wa ta'ala will
multiply your reward and as a prophet
said that every deed will get a reward
times and in this month it's very easy
to enter jenah when a prophet said the
Gates of Hell will be closed indicating
that to enter hell is difficult in this
month why because your TAA level
rises and the chance of you to commit
sin is less and furthermore if you fast
the full month in the month of Ramadan
seeking Allah's reward all your past
will be forgiven so the moment a person
fast in this complete month of Ramadan
seeking Allah's reward all this past
sins are completely forgiven so if the
past sins are forgiven the chances of
him going to hell is nil
but what we have to realize the
criteria for the Gates of Heaven to be
open and the Gates of Hell to be closed
is that you have to
fast and
furthermore to enter Jenna you require a
ticket the ticket to go to Jenna is
mentioned in the Quran in Surah Al
chapter number 103 verse number 1 to 3
where Allah
says
that by the token of time man is verily
in a state of loss except those who have
faith those who righteous deeds those
who exalt people to truth and those who
exal people to patience and perseverance
this Surah according to Imam Shafi he
said that only if this Surah was to be
revealed of the Quran it would have been
sufficient for the Salvation of mankind
so important is it is called as ra the
way for salvation and the criteria for
any human being to enter Jenna is four
first is Iman second
is righteous Deeds third is exalting
people to truth and fourth is exalting
people to patience and perseverance so
here we realize that the Gates of Heaven
are open but just because the gates are
open you can't enter you require the
ticket the ticket is Iman the tiet is
righteous deed exalting people to truth
exalting people to patient students and
to get this ticket is very easy in the
month of
Ramadan because the Iman level rises in
the month of Ramadan furthermore your
righteous deed the reward is
Multiplied it's easier you can call
people to truth your patient level
increases so this Hadith means that you
have to have the criteria that inshallah
you should go to Jenna and you will not
go to hell but that doesn't mean that
100% people who die will go to Jenna
surely those who are not believers they
have got no Iman so there's no question
that they will enter
Jenna if a person has to enter Jenna he
requires a ticket and the ticket to
Jenna is Sur Al furthermore if you read
the Hadith it says that only if you fast
in the month of
Ramadan that means and you follow all
the rules and regulations and abstain
from things which are prohibited then
the dose of heaven will be open and the
Gates of Hell will be closed furthermore
it says in this month is a night which
is equivalent to more than thousand
months indicating that even if you pray
and worship to Allah subhana wa ta'ala
in this one night it will equivalent to
more than a thousand months is about
more than 180 years imagine so the
chances for you to get reward only in
this one night is more than a lifetime
an average human being Liv for 60 years
so one
is more than a th months is about more
than 180 years more than average life of
a human being the chances are very easy
to go to J and the ending part of the
Hadith says a person who's
deprived of these blessings is truly a
deprived person indicating that everyone
will not go to Jenna everyone will not
find the doors of Heaven open it says
the ending part very important that a
person is deprived of the blessings this
month is truly a deprived person that
means telling us Muslims that if you
cannot get the benefits of the month of
Ramadan and then if you cannot go to
Jenna then you are truly a deprived
person that even includes the
non-muslims who haven't got the they're
truly the deprived
people so Dr Zak well and I thank you
for those intriguing answers
particularly pertaining to the last two
questions which you answer so eloquently
mashallah alhamdulillah
brothers and sisters I hope you
benefited as much as I did today I
listened to the show and tomorrow we
shall be discussing an introduction to
Ramadan inshallah alaykum until tomorrow
at the same
[Music]
time
for
e